Hey YouTubers! It's Charlie. This is going to be my non-spoilery
Avengers:Age of Ultron review.
Basically like THE BIGGEST Marvel movie you will ever see.
After seeing it and listening to some of the interviews he's done it's easy to understand why Joss Whedon
kind of wants to transition from doing Marvel films to doing really small indie films
and just consulting on all of the phase three films.
Seriously the first cut of the film was three and a half hours long.
The end running time is closer to like two and a half hours so it's
still really long.
Pro Tip: I would recommend you get the small drink
lest you have to leave the theater like three or four times to go to the bathroom.
I know I shouldn't be surprised too but I got home from my screening
and I was already being tweeted links
from like pirated WTF scenes in the movie.
I was a little surprised at how fast it happened. I mean everything leaks eventually
but I know it wasn't someone inside the movie theater that I was at.
The print that I saw was like the eleventh film
in an eleven film marathon and after
every movie they would cycle us in and out of the theater.
Before Avengers: Age of Ultron
they took all of our phones
and wanded us down like we were getting ready to go on an airplane.
If you're not familiar with it The El Capitan, the place where they did this big Marvel marathon,
is the same theater,
a couple months ago, where they did their big phase three announcement. Where they announced Captain America: Civil War,
all the other films that are going to be happening for the next five years.
They joke that in another five years they'll turn it into like a
thirty-six hour movie marathon
so you'll have your chance in another five years to do this again.
Just to talk about the characters a little bit
Joss Whedon said going into this that this was going to be
much more of a Hulk/Hawkeye film
vs. the other Avengers. You know typically Tony Stark,
Captain America, they're the biggest characters.
In this film he chooses to focus on some of the lesser characters.
It's really fun when you go back and watch Mark Ruffalo's Hulk performance in
Avengers 1 and then you watch it now.
Just to see how he's evolved.
The film itself isn't constructed so much on the big action set pieces
in the way that the first Avengers film was constructed.
Joss Whedon said that when he went to write this
he built it based on the moments
between characters that he wanted to see so
this is like the biggest Marvel character film that you've ever seen.
That's why I think it will be easier for this film to
stand the test of time then like the other big Marvel films.
There are a couple things weighing it down. Like I said it's a two and an half hour movie so there's
a lot of stuff in there.
Maybe not like every single character you've ever seen in the history of the Marvel universe
but just about.
If you are a big Joss Whedon fan like a fan of the way he
writes jokes and his Shakespearean style
this is gonna be your big film.
He said going into the first Avenger's film
He joined the team, the production team, a little late in the game so
he didn't have as much time to make it his own film as he did in this film.
Literally the idea for this film came
when he went to have his first meeting with Marvel about Avengers 1.
he explained that that was all about Ultron. He's like
"I want Ultron to be the villain,
and I want Paul Bettany to become The Vision".
That was the Marvel film that he wanted to make
whenever he was meeting for Avengers 1.
So he was like "okay I'll do this Avengers film but
then I want to do this other big Avenger's film"
and Kevin Feige was like "ok that's great let's do that".
The fun thing about this big Marvel marathon is that Kevin Feige actually came for several of the films to intro them.
They would roll out like writers like James Gunn came to
intro Guardians of the Galaxy when they got to that.
Jaimie Alexander came to introduce Thor: The Dark World so they had like big directors come out
and before they screened Age of Ultron they actually
they showed a 3D print of the Ant Man trailer.
I think Ant Man is going to be a lot of fun in 3D but we can talk about that later.
Even though the film centers very much on Hulk and Hawkeye
really the break away stars, the ones you'll walk away thinking about the most, I think are
Paul Bettany's performance as The Vision,
and James Spader's performance as Ultron.
Just to start with Ultron
he is probably the funniest, scariest robot you will ever see in a movie.
If you've ever watched Blacklist, it's a very dark drama show, his
character Raymond Reddington gets a lot of jokes in.
Think of it as humor in that sense, only if it were written by Joss Whedon.
So it's like Joss Whedon jokes,
flowing from the darkest, scariest mouth you can possibly imagine.
In another week when we get to my spoilery review I can explain a little bit better
why he's such a funny character, just because there's some specific plot points tied to it.
Paul Bettany as the vision though, I'm really interested to see
which female fans walk away from this film
fangirling on him vs.
like Bucky in Captain America: The Winter Solider,
or Chris Evans, or Thor, or like
people you would normally expect people to fangirl on.
Some of the most GIFable moments in the film are Vision moments.
Seriously once this movie hits DVD
Tumblr is gonna explode. It's gonna be so much fun.
The reason I think that Paul Bettany worked so well as The Vision,
is Joss Whedon comes from this
Shakespeare place where a lot of his creative energy comes from
and Paul Bettany is amazing at that so
Joss Whedon's words coming out of Paul Bettany's mouth
just sounds so much better than any other choices they could have made for the Vision character.
a big part of that casting choice was also tied up in the plot of the movie
Jarvis himself is actually a really interesting character in this film.
He's very distinct
from the Vision character.
Even though Paul Bettany does voices for both.
Just to be clear Jarvis is more of an ethereal
cloud, like there's no face attached to him.
Vision though is like literally Paul Bettany walking around on screen.
It's not motion capture.
That's why I can not wait to see how they integrate Vision in to the
future phase three films.
They haven't made any announcements yet so I don't have any rumors to give you guys.
Right now the biggest complaint I'm seeing from traditional critics
is there's so much of the film dedicated to setting up the phase three films,
but that's expected. They told us they were going to do that.
I feel like if you go into a Marvel film
you expect them to set up other films in some ways using
using post credit scenes, using plot points.
So there is a lot of that in there but it is important and you'll understand why when you see the film.
They do a good job of setting up the other phase three films without like
going on a wide tangent.
Like they don't derail the film just to set up Thor 3, Captain America: Civil War.
I feel like even though they crammed
everything and the kitchen sink into the movie, it works much better thematically than the first Avengers film.
Like you could argue that the first Avengers film is just a bunch of big action set pieces
sewn together.
This film flows much more like a traditional film.
Like it's not just them flying from big fight, to big fight, to big fight.
I think one of my few disappointments with the film is that we didn't spend
quite as much time as I wanted to with the Black Widow character.
But I totally understand why they can't do that. Like
it's a big film, they already have so much in there
they can only spend so much time with the characters.
Joss Whedon really chose to go with Hulk and Hawkeye.
Then you have to work in four new characters including Ultron, Vision,
Quicksilver, and Scarlet Witch.
You have to give them their moments too.
I know a lot of people feel weird about Quicksilver's accent.
It's not that big a thing. Like it won't completely take you out of the film.
Really the break away Maximoff twin is Elizabeth Olsen but she's a great actress. I'm actually a big fan of hers.
If you haven't seen any of her indie stuff, check out some of her indie films.
She's like one of those actors like Mark Ruffalo that will do a big film like this
but most of the time they spend there time doing really small character films
that I think are much more rewarding for the actors.
Yes you get the giant paycheck for the big Avengers film,
but if you really want like a challenging character film you really have to make a small indie film yourself.
That's why I'm really hoping at some point to see some collaboration with Robert Downey Jr.'s
Team Downey Films, that's like his production company that he uses to make films,
and Mark Ruffalo.
Like Mark Ruffalo makes a film,
funded by Team Downey. That would be amazing.
Robert Downey Jr. is a really interesting presence in the film.
You get a sense that in real life he senses like "ok I'm getting a little long lidded too so
I can't hold these films up by myself". "We need to start relying on the ensemble."
So they weave him into the film and kind of explain where his character is going in the future
in a way that will allow him to take a diminished role.
Thematically going into Captain America: Civil War next year you'll
understand why even though he's in the film, it's still a Captain America Chris Evans film.
A lot of people are choosing to call that Avengers 2.5 and it kind of is because there's going to be a
ton of characters in there.
But it will still be a Captain America film.
Walking away from the film the character that I'm most excited to see more from in the phase three films
is Paul Bettany as The Vision.
If you're a big comic book fan you've probably read some Vision stories before. You understand like
why it's such an interesting character to explore in the future.
Even of you're just seeing him for the first time in Age of Ultron
you'll totally understand. Like after you see his scenes
You'll totally understand why he is the most interesting character in the history of the Marvel Universe.
I will go as far to say that Vision
is so much fun that I will totally not be pissed if
they cut Adam Warlock out of Guardians of the Galaxy 2.
Like if they don't do Adam Warlock at all in the Marvel Universe,
I will totally be happy if Vision becomes his place holder.
I realize that gets into like Thanos/Infinity Gauntlet story line stuff.
I'll save a lot of that for my spoiler review just because the film does address that in a really interesting way.
So be sure to subscribe to get that.
What I'll do is probably wait until the film is going to released in the United States
because I think it's the last place that it's dropping.
That should be May first so it should be about a week or so before I post that video.
Be sure to ask any specific plot point questions you have and if you've seen the film
and you want to comment on spoilers,
just please use a spoiler tag just like you do on my Game of Thrones videos.
So what's happening next is I'm going to post my Arrow video next
because that's tonight. Then I'll get through Agents of Shield,
and then I'll try to get through the rest of  my Daredevil videos before the weekend.
Daredevil has been picked up for season two but the show runners are going to be different so
whenever I post my next Daredevil video I'll explain that.
Or at least by my Agents of Shield video.
Just in case you guys haven't seen it you can
click here for last night's episode of The Flash, I just
posted that super early this morning,
and you can click here for all my other Avengers/Marvel videos.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody lets high five. I'll see you guys tonight.